the day hadn't started yet and yet there
were I would estimate you know 12 to 15
ambulances waiting outside Lisa Jane
Hinckley has cancer her thyroid
operation was urgent but this isn't how
she or her husband Liam imagined it on
Wednesday she waited eight hours inside
the Gloucester Royal hospital without
food or water her private consultations
taking place in a public Corridor the
rooms around her bursting with patients
using broken toilets the hospital has
apologized to Lisa Jane saying they're
facing unprecedented circumstances and
extraordinary levels of demand
we are in a crisis at the in the NHS and
to now suddenly be faced with being a
person a patient in that environment is
really worrying and stressful it was
awful for for us as well for Lisa as a
patient uh but you know she gets patched
up comes home but these people are
having to work in that environment day
in Day Out
[Applause]
it's these conditions that have prompted
NHS strikes this and more pay as staff
tackle a triple democ of flu covered and
emergency department pressures
the Royal College of nurses says it's
willing to reduce its demands and the
Prime Minister says he's willing to talk
we incredibly value the important work
that our public sector workers do
especially our nurses and we want to
have an honest grown-up conversation
about what's affordable what's
responsible for the country
in just a few days time ambulance
workers will walk out more pressure on a
system facing a record number of
ambulance Suites and while both sides
have shown a willingness to talk their
positions remain the same
Sky News understands the health
secretary has invited members of the NHS
staff Council to discuss next year's pay
review body pay increases but some
striking unions are reluctant unless
they can discuss their ongoing disputes
it's prompted many to ask if the NHS can
cope with surging infections record
demand and Industrial action we are
working closely with the unions to
ensure that we maintain the highest
possible quality of care during those
days of action and of course keep
patients safe but of course there will
be disruption I can't deny that and that
means other families in Lisa Jane and
Liam's position could see their
operations canceled and their health put
at risk Ashish Joshi Sky News